OKAY. WE ARE GOING TO BRING THIS
MEETING TO ORDER. THIS IS THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
DO YOU NEED A SECOND OR ARE YOU
READY? ARE YOU READY? OKAY,
GREAT. WE HAVE THREE BILLS ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY. BUT BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL,
WE'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SO, ASSISTANT, WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? SENATORS BLAKE
SPEER, PRESENT BLAKE SPEER,
PRESENT. WHEN? HERE. WHEN HERE.
ASHBY. MENGIBAR HERE. MENGIBAR
HERE. NEWMAN. PORTANTINO UMBERG
HERE. UMBERG HERE. OKAY. THANK
YOU, IF THERE ARE ANY AUTHORS
WHO ARE WATCHING THIS ON
TELEVISION, PLEASE COME DOWN TO
ROOM 2100. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE WATCHING NOW, OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING, WHICH IS
CALLED ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
AND ELECTIONS PROTECTING
DEMOCRACY IN THE DIGITAL ERA,
THAT WILL LIKELY BEGIN AROUND 10
A.M. OR UPON ADJOURNMENT OF THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING. SO WE WILL BE
JUMPING INTO OUR BILLS AS SOON
AS WE HAVE THE AUTHORS APPEAR,
AND WE'LL HEAD INTO A SHORT
RECESS. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. VALENCIA, ARE
YOU READY? OKAY. WELL. SO WE
WILL HEAR OUR FIRST BILL, WHICH
IS AB 1170 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALENCIA. HE IS PREPARED. WE
INVITE YOU TO COME FORWARD.
BUENOS DIAS. AND THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT 1170. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS MEASURE THUS
FAR, SINCE JANUARY OF 2017, THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION HAS OPERATED AND
MAINTAINED AN ELECTRONIC FILING
SYSTEMS OF FORM SEVEN HUNDREDS.
EVEN THOUGH THE MAJORITY OF
FILERS ALREADY FILED THROUGH THE
FPC'S E FILING SYSTEM. THE
ACTION IS CURRENTLY VOLUNTARY.
AB 1170 MAKES A SIGNIFICANT
SHIFT FOR THE FPCS FORM 700,
TRANSITIONING IT TO A FULLY
ELECTRONIC FILING SYSTEM THAT
REQUIRES FILERS TO DO SO ONLINE.
THIS CHANGE IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
EFFICIENCY, IT WILL ALSO REDUCE
STAFF TIME AND SAVE THE STATE
MONEY. MOST IMPORTANTLY BY
EMBRACING A FULLY ELECTRONIC
SYSTEM. AB 1170 IS TO SET. IT'S
SET TO IMPROVE THE CURRENT
STATUS QUO. THE EXISTING SYSTEM
IS OUTDATED, INACCESSIBLE AND
FALLS SHORT OF GOOD GOVERNANCE
PRACTICES. CURRENTLY THE FPC
REGULATIONS REQUIRE ONLY THE
FORM 700 OF ELECTED OFFICIALS TO
BE POSTED ONLINE WITH THEIR
SIGNATURES REDACTED. HOWEVER,
1170 WILL ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE ABILITY TO
DECIDE WHAT INFORMATION SHALL BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
WITH THE SHIFT. WITH THIS SHIFT,
WE CAN TRULY ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY AND GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY. I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES CAN
ACCESS THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO HOLD THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS
ACCOUNTABLE. AND WITH ME TODAY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS LINDSAY
NAKANO, THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL AT THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICE COMMISSION. THANK YOU.
AS THE LEAD WITNESS, YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS LINDSAY NAKANO,
SENIOR LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL WITH
THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION, STATEMENTS OF
ECONOMIC INTEREST OR FORM 700,
ARE A CRUCIAL INSTRUMENTS FOR
TRANSPARENCY IN THE CONTEXT OF
FINANCIAL CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
THAT MAY ARISE DURING THE
GOVERNMENTAL DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. ABOUT 25,000
INDIVIDUALS FILE FORM 700 WITH
THE COMMISSION EACH YEAR, AND
SINCE 2017, THE COMMISSION HAS
MAINTAINED THE SUCCESSFUL
ELECTRONIC FILING SYSTEM THAT AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF FILERS HAVE
OPTED TO USE OVER THE YEARS. AB
1170 WOULD COMPLETE THE
TRANSITION FROM PAPER TO
ELECTRONIC FILING BY REQUIRING
FILERS FOR WHOM THE COMMISSION
IS THE FILING OFFICER TO FILE
THEIR FORM 700 THROUGH THE E
FILING SYSTEM. THE BILL WOULD
WOULD REDUCE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN OF PROCESSING, SCANNING
AND MANUALLY REDACTING PAPER
FILINGS AND WOULD ALSO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
FILERS. THANK YOU TO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I VOTE
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
LEAD WITNESSES? NO. THAT'S IT.
OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. DO
WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
? I DON'T SEE ANY ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM. I
APOLOGIZE, I DIDN'T ASK FOR THAT
YET. NOT SEEING ANY. OKAY. WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? I WILL
JUST THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION. I'LL JUST SHARE THAT. I
AGREE THAT IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO BE HAVING FORM SEVEN HUNDREDS
FILED IN MULTIPLE FORMATS. AND
AS A LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIAL,
JUST TWO YEARS AGO, I FILED IT
IN THREE SEPARATE WAYS BECAUSE
OF THE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT THE
AGENCIES REQUESTED IT. SO TWO
DIFFERENT ONLINE ONES, WHICH
WERE EXACTLY IDENTICAL, AND THEN
ALSO ONE IN PRINT. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL AND THINK
IT'S A GOOD DIRECTION TO BE
GOING. AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT. SO WITH THAT, I
WILL ASK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU. AND TO YOUR
COMMENTS. CHAIRWOMAN, YOUR
EXPERIENCE IS NOT ALONE IN THIS.
AND AS CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON SEVEN AND
ACCOUNTABILITY, I HAVE I FEEL A
DEEP RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
THAT OUR GOVERNMENT REMAINS NOT
ONLY TRANSPARENT, BUT
ACCOUNTABLE, SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
SENATOR UMBERG HAS MOVED AB
1170. SO THE MOTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS BLAKE SPEER I
SPEER I1I1I ASHBY MENGIBAR
NEWMAN PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
UMBERG I UMBERG I. OKAY IT IS
FOUR ZERO AND WE WILL KEEP IT ON
CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. NEXT I SEE WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR WHO HAS JUST ARRIVED.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. OUR NEXT ITEM WILL BE
AB 2249 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. AND WE INVITE YOU TO
COME FORWARD AND PRESENT YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATORS,
I'D LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND
THANKING COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE. UNDER
EXISTING LAW, SPECIFIC ELECTION
MATERIALS MUST BE RETAINED BY
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
RECORDS REGARDING FEDERAL
ELECTIONS MUST BE RETAINED FOR
22 MONTHS AND ALL OTHER ELECTION
RECORDS MUST BE RETAINED FOR SIX
MONTHS. THE PACKAGES CONTAINING
THESE MATERIALS MUST REMAIN
UNOPENED AND FOR THE DURATION OF
THE RETENTION PERIOD, AFTER
WHICH THESE MATERIALS ARE
DESTROYED. IN THE PURSUIT OF
TRANSPARENT ELECTIONS. THE
PRESERVATION OF THE PAPER AND
ELECTRONIC RECORD OF THE
ELECTION IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. HOWEVER, THERE HAVE
BEEN CASES WHERE THE SECRETARY
OF STATE AND A COURT HAVE COME
TO DIFFERING CONCLUSIONS
REGARDING WHICH DOCUMENTS MAY BE
SHARED WITHOUT COMPROMISING THE
SECURITY OF THE ELECTIONS. IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE MORE CLARITY
REGARDING RETENTION AND DOCUMENT
ACCESS, AB 2249 CLARIFIES WHICH
MATERIALS MUST BE RETAINED BY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. AB 2249
ADDS PAPER CAST VOTE RECORDS,
COMPLETED FORMS ISSUED TO THE
PRECINCT BOARD AND MACHINE
REPORTS USED TO ACCOUNT FOR
BALLOTS DELIVERED TO THE POLLING
PLACE, AND COMPLETED FORMS
ISSUED TO THE COUNTY BOARDS AND
MACHINE REPORTS USED FOR THE 1%
MANUAL TALLY TO THE LIST OF
MATERIALS THAT ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS ARE REQUIRED TO KEEP.
CAST VOTE RECORDS ARE AUDITABLE
DOCUMENTS THAT CORRESPOND TO THE
SELECTIONS MADE ON THE VOTER'S
BALLOT. VOTER IDENTIFICATION
ENVELOPES CONTAINING THE VOTER'S
SIGNATURE, RESIDENTIAL ADDRESS,
DATE OF SIGNATURE, AND NOTICE
THAT VOTING MORE THAN ONCE
CONSTITUTES A CRIME. AMONG OTHER
NOTICES, AB 2249 CLARIFIES THAT
ALL VOTERS MAY INSPECT THE
CONTENTS OF THE PACKAGE OR
PACKAGES AT ALL TIMES DURING THE
OFFICIAL CANVASS AND RETENTION
PERIOD, EXCEPTING THOSE ITEMS
THAT CONTAIN SIGNATURES OF
VOTERS WHICH MAY NOT BE COPIED
OR DISTRIBUTED. IN ORDER TO
PRESERVE THE SECRECY OF THE
BALLOT, AB 2249 IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS,
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS TRICIA WEBER,
REPRESENTING CA, CA, CEO. OKAY.
THANK YOU. PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. AND AS A LEAD
WITNESS, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
BLAKE SPEER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS TRICIA
WEBER, AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS.
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLANS.
AB 2249. THIS BILL AIMS TO
PROVIDE CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY
ON RECORDS RETENTION DURING THE
COURSE OF AN ELECTION. OFFICIALS
USE A LOT OF DIFFERENT SUPPLIES,
MATERIALS AND FORMS AT THEIR
VOTING LOCATIONS AND DURING THE
CANVASS. ADDITIONALLY TO PROVIDE
VOTERS A GOOD VOTING EXPERIENCE
SUCH AS SAME DAY REGISTRATION
ENVELOPES AND FORMS MUST BE USED
. ELECTION OFFICIALS STORE THESE
ITEMS UNDER SEAL, WITH THE
BALLOTS THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR
THE REQUIRED RETENTION PERIOD.
HOWEVER, THERE IS AMBIGUITY IN
THE ELECTIONS CODE REGARDING
THESE FORMS. SUPPLIES,
ENVELOPES, AND MATERIALS IN
TERMS OF HOW, OR EVEN IF THEY
SHOULD BE RETAINED. AB 2249
ADDRESSES THIS AMBIGUITY AND
CLEARLY STATES WHAT NEEDS TO BE
RETAINED. HOW LONG IT NEEDS TO
BE STORED, AND HOW LONG ELECTION
OFFICIALS WILL KEEP THEM. I'M
SORRY HOW THEY NEED TO BE STORED
AND HOW LONG ELECTION OFFICIALS
WILL NEED TO KEEP THEM. THIS
BILL ALSO ADDRESSES HOW TO
HANDLE SEALED DOCUMENTS IN THE
CASE OF A NATURAL DISASTER.
UNFORTUNATELY, SEVERAL COUNTIES
HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS, NEED TO
COME UP WITH A WAY TO MAKE IT TO
DEAL WITH THESE STORED DOCUMENTS
WHEN THEY'RE DESTROYED OR
POSSIBLY MAY BE DESTROYED BY THE
DISASTER. FOR AB 2249 LAYS OUT A
CLEAR PLAN FOR COUNTIES TO
FOLLOW SO THAT THERE IS
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE ON
HOW TO PRESERVE THESE IMPORTANT
DOCUMENTS. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE, AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM? PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND STATE YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION
AND IF YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
ETHAN NAGLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY CLERKS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING. I'M ERIC LARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? OKAY.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHO ARE
IN THE ROOM NOT SEEING ANY
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION WHO WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THEIR NAME, NOT
SEEING ANY. SO DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE? NOT
SEEING ANY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
UMBERG. SENATOR ELLENBERG MOVES
THE BILL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
A CLOSING STATEMENT? I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY.
THANK YOU. SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND
HAVE A MOTION. HAVE A VOTE ON
MOTION MADE BY SENATOR UMBERG
FOR AB 21 2749 OH, I'M SORRY, AB
20 2249 I APOLOGIZE. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATORS
BLAKE SPEER, A BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
ONE. ASHBY. ASHBY AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. NEWMAN
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO. AYE.
UMBERG UMBERG. AYE. IT IS FIVE
ZERO, AND WE WILL KEEP IT ON
CALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. OKAY, NEXT I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. HE IS IN THE ROOM
AND HE IS PREPARED. SO WE WILL
INVITE YOU TO COME FORWARD. AB
2127 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN.
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK
YOU. CHAIR BLAKE. AND SENATORS
CALIFORNIA'S NEW MOTOR VOTER LAW
HAS BEEN A HAS BEEN A STRONG
SUCCESS WITH NEARLY 26 MILLION
NEW OR UPDATED VOTER
REGISTRATIONS SINCE IT LAUNCHED
IN 2018. NOTWITHSTANDING THIS
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENT,
THERE HAVE BEEN CHALLENGES
MODERNIZING THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS AT THE DMV,
ULTIMATELY RESULTING IN
LITIGATION AND SETTLEMENT,
CREATED OVERSIGHT MECHANISMS. I
AUTHORED LEGISLATION IN 2021 TO
CODIFY MANY OF THE BEST
PRACTICES FROM THE LEGAL
SETTLEMENT, AS WELL AS ESTABLISH
THE NEW MOTOR VOTER TASK FORCE
TO CONTINUE MONITORING THE LAW'S
ROLLOUT AND ADVISE THE SECRETARY
OF STATE AND DMV ON ITS
EFFECTIVENESS ON ITS EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION. THÀNH. WHILE OUR
MOTOR VOTER LAW HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL, THERE ARE SEVERAL
UPDATES AND CHANGES FORTHCOMING
AS WELL AS TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN
DELAYS. THEREFORE AB 2127 WOULD
EXTEND THE OPERATION OF THE TASK
FORCE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
CONTINUED OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE
PROPER IMPLEMENTATION AND THE
FULL EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR NEW
MOTOR VOTER LAW. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES HERE
AND I DO. I THANK YOU FOR
ASKING. I'M JOINED TODAY BY
BRITTANY STONECIPHER, WHO IS AN
ATTORNEY FOR THE ACLU AND A
MEMBER OF THE NEW MOTOR VOTER
TASK FORCE. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS BRITTANY STONECIPHER. ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
AND A PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB
2127, WE WORK TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DEMOCRACY IS
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL VOTERS,
INCLUDING HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS. WE AND
OUR PARTNERS HAVE SPENT MANY
YEARS ADVOCATING TO INCREASE THE
FAIRNESS AND EFFICIENCY OF THE
VOTER REGISTRATION SYSTEM AT THE
DMV. THE CURRENT NEW MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM IS A BYPRODUCT OF THAT
ONGOING COLLABORATION. SINCE ITS
ROLLOUT IN 2018, THE NEW MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM HAS BECOME ONE OF
THE MOST POWERFUL TOOLS THAT THE
STATE HAS FOR MAINTAINING
ACCURATE VOTER ROLLS AND
REGISTERING NEW VOTERS IN ONLY
SIX YEARS, THE PROGRAM HAS
REGISTERED OR UPDATED THE
REGISTRATIONS OF OVER 26 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. THE DMV IS NOW THE
TOP REGISTRATION METHOD FOR
YOUTH AND VOTERS OF COLOR. THE
PROGRAM SUCCESS ACTIVELY RELIES
ON MONITORING AND GUIDANCE FROM
STAKEHOLDERS. THIS IS WHY THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED THE NEW
MOTOR VOTER TASK FORCE IN 2021,
FORMALLY CONVENING STAKEHOLDERS
WITH THE DMV AND THE SECRETARY
OF STATE. SINCE THEN, THE TASK
FORCE HAS PROVIDED VISIBILITY
INTO ISSUES AT THE DMV AND
DEVELOPED GUIDANCE FOR
STREAMLINING REGISTRATION FORMS.
THE TASK FORCE ALSO PUBLISHES
ANNUAL REPORTS, WHICH ARE
INVALUABLE RESOURCES FOR THE
PUBLIC, LAWMAKERS, AND
ADVOCATES. THE NEXT REPORT WILL
BE PUBLISHED LATER THIS MONTH.
DESPITE A SUCCESSES, THE TASK
FORCE WILL SUNSET AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR. UNLESS IT'S EXTENDED.
THE DMV IS CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN
A MAJOR OVERHAUL OF ITS SOFTWARE
SYSTEMS, DELAYING MAJOR
IMPROVEMENTS AND CRITICAL
UPDATES THAT WILL MAXIMIZE THE
PROGRAM'S ABILITY TO ENGAGE
POTENTIAL VOTERS. IF THE TASK
FORCE EXPIRES AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR AS SCHEDULED, WE WILL LOSE
A NECESSARY TOOL FOR EFFECTIVELY
AND TRANSPARENTLY IMPLEMENTING
THESE CHANGES. AB 2127 WILL
EXTEND PUBLIC OVERSIGHT AND
TECHNICAL GUIDANCE DURING THIS
PERIOD OF COMPLEX TRANSITION.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE,
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ADD THEIR SUPPORT?
ADRIANA. CHAMPAGNE ZAMORA WITH
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA, PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO LEAD WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY IN THE
ROOM? I DON'T SEE ANY, ANYBODY
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WITH YOUR NAME, TITLE
AND OPPOSITION? NO. OKAY. SO
THANK YOU, WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE MEMBERS. ANYBODY ON THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS OR ASK QUESTIONS? I DO
NOT SEE ANY. SO NOW WE WILL, GO
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN FOR
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
I SEE THAT YOUR HAND IS NOT
QUITE FULLY RECOVERED FROM THE
SOCCER GAME. THERE'LL BE A BE
ABOUT A MONTH. OKAY. YEAH, WELL,
THANK YOU FOR SACRIFICING YOUR
YOUR OWN, YOUR OWN SELF FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE TEAM. ONE DAY
I'LL LEARN. YEAH DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? OKAY. SENATOR MENGIBAR
HAS MOVED AB 2127. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION ASSISTANT. WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
SENATORS BLAKE SPEER, I LAKE
SPEER I ONE NO. ONE, NO. ASHBY.
ASHBY I MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
UMBERG UMBERG I THANK YOU, SIR.
OKAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT. THANKS. IT'S 5 TO
1. WE'LL KEEP IT ON CALL. SHOULD
WE LIFT THE CALL SINCE WE HAVE
ANOTHER MEMBER HERE? YES OKAY.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND LIFT THE
CALL. LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM
ONE AB 1170. CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTED. I MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY.
ASHBY Ã. ASHBY I. MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. SIX ZERO
OKAY. IT'S SIX ZERO. STILL ON
CALL.
OKAY. WE WILL KEEP IT ON CALL
AND WE WILL COME BACK WHEN OUR
FINAL MEMBER ARRIVES, WHICH WILL
BE SHORTLY. SO THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED
TODAY. IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY, PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS. WE WILL, TAKE A
BRIEF RECESS FOR OUR LAST MEMBER
TO APPEAR, AND THEN WE WILL
RESCHEDULE OURSELVES A LITTLE
BIT AND COME BACK FOR OUR JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON AI AND
ELECTIONS. SO WITH THAT, WE'RE
IN A BRIEF RECESS.
OKAY, WE'RE BACK FROM RECESS,
AND WE ARE LIFTING THE CALL ON
ALL OF THE BILLS. FILE ITEM ONE,
AB 1170. MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY. CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX ZERO. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I 770. IT'S OUT.
LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM TWO AB
2127. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
TRANSPORTATION. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ONE. CHAIR VOTED I VICE
CHAIR VOTED NO. NEWMAN A NEWMAN
I 6161. IT'S OUT LIFTING CALL ON
FILE ITEM THREE AB 2249. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE WHEN
NEWMAN NEWMAN I. 6060. IT'S OUT
OKAY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
THIS COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. THE
NEXT THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT
COMMITTEE WILL START. OKAY,
OKAY. THE NEXT COMMITTEE WILL
START ON TIME AT TEN. SO PLEASE
BE ON TIME. IF YOU ARE A MEMBER
OF THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE OR THE SENATE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
I'LL BE BACK. OKAY. AND JUST FOR
INFORMATION, IN CASE ANYBODY IS
CURIOUS, THE NEXT COMMITTEE IS
CALLED. OR THE COST. WHERE'S
WHERE'S THE NAME OF IT AGAIN?
OKAY. OKAY. THE NEXT WHAT WE ARE
DOING AT TEN IS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING, ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
AND ELECTIONS, PROTECTING
DEMOCRACY IN THE DIGITAL ERA.
AND WE WILL SEE EVERYONE AT TEN.
WITH THAT, WE'RE ADJOURNED.